ZACH WERENSKI FINDS THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE ICE JEFF.
BUT WHAT A PLAY BY JAKE.
HE JUST WAITED.
IS DEFINITELY IN.
>> IT LO
OUTSIDE OF THE PAD GOOD STRENGTH
BY COVER IT UP.
>> YOU CAN
TAMPA TWO FOR SCHENEN OFF.
BO HOUR VAST THE CAPTAIN OF THE
CANUCKS TAKE IT OUT OF PLAY GOOD
HIT THERE ALOLO THE STRIDE THERD
JUST A WORLD T T JACKETS COME OF
THEIR OWN ZONE.
CROSS THE LEF
FRONT, DRILLED WIDE OF THE NET.
DOWN
THERE, THAT CHINAKHOV GOAL CAME
ON THE RIGHTAKHOV MISSES THAT D
STAYS WITH IT.
IT'S A BIG PLAY AS HE GETS IT
LO SEND IT
OFF INTO THE CORNERFENDS IN THE,
CHIASSON COMESESUCK DOWN AROUND.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S GOT LANE TO
ATTACK RIGHT HERE BUT HE IN VAN.
>> JT MILLER.
SENDS IT OFF THE
THAT AGAIN.
>> I CUT YOU OFF THAT'S WHAT AW.
BEAN THROUGH A CROWD, IT WAS MAS
IS OKAY.
>> VANCOUVER'S GOAL.
THE DYING MINUTE OF PERIOD CONT.
SHOT BACK HERE TO GAVRIKOV,
QUICK ONE-TIMER THERE BYIC GOING
TO GET IT HIGH.
WAY
DISMAY CLEARING PASS
AND GOT GIVE THEM CREDIT HERE
TONIGHT.
THEY PLAYED WITH A SENSE OF
URGENCY FROM THE OPEN FACE-OFF.
EXTRA EMPHASIS BACK.
BOESER.
HORVAT.
OFF THE POINT.  ZONE DOMI.
HOW HOHO